hey guys pete here just finished
watching the watchman season finale and
wow i really enjoyed it
this will be a top moments recap and
reaction sort of thing
i've only watched it once at this point
so it's not going to be a deep dive
but the hype is real and i wanted to
talk about it later this week i will put
out some more videos to take a closer
look
this video will contain spoilers for the
first season of watchmen on hbo
if you haven't watched the season finale
yet this video is not for you
please watch that and then come back
just hit the subscribe button before you
leave
we have to start at the ending because
that is the elephant in the room and not
that elephant
that elephant was apparently just a host
to help clear out angela's brain
after taking hooded justice's nostalgia
i'm talking about angela eating the egg
and us not getting to see what happens
when she attempts to walk on water
if you're anything like me you were
sitting there on the edge of your seat i
half expected her to fall into the water
and not be able to walk on it but in the
end we don't find out what happens
i'll talk about it as an ending more
later when i get into will reeve's story
and the conclusion of john osterman and
angela's story
before that though i will say that damon
lindelof the series creator
spoke with deadline and they asked him
straight out if this was going to be the
end of the series
he says he doesn't know that's the
answer and to quote
all i can say is i've consistently
believed and still believed that these
nine episodes are a complete story with
a beginning middle and end
i have to acknowledge that not
everyone's going to see it that way and
i definitely don't dispute any opinion
that's sort of like there should be more
i just don't feel compelled to continue
the story without a reason to do so
that reason should be a creative reason
idea driven
and i don't have any ideas for
subsequent seasons of watchmen
currently he goes on to say where i'll
paraphrase that
that every show's ending if it doesn't
have the destruction of creation
could potentially continue if anyone's
still alive the world could be
continuing so we'll leave that
discussion there for now
and i'll get into my favorite moments of
this episode
first on that list is the ozymandias
lady true parentage reveal
i loved how her mother stole his seed
and i loved how
alexander the great was staring down as
she did the inseminating there in his
office
overall i think this makes sense it was
pretty good as soon as i saw the camera
pull back and the cameraman was
vietnamese i was sure that that was how
things were going to go and i really
enjoyed that call back to
karnak from the original comic book i
really enjoyed their
introductions i really enjoyed the way
that they got to know each other
her using the idea that no one gives him
credit for the wonderful work he did for
saving the world
her explaining her plan to take dr
manhattan's power set the stage
him challenging her to do it on her own
without his help and of course
him saying that he will never call her
daughter which leads us
right into the next one and the next big
moment is the escape from europa
we find out that it was save me daughter
that he spelled out with the crookshanks
and phillips's corpses
she comes through sends him an escape
craft and this whole sequence was
fantastic
we find out that he created the game
warden persona had him wear a mask
because
masks make men cruel and he did it all
to have a worthy adversary the look on
his face when he's walking away
him catching the bullet and having that
whole thing set up
just to satisfy his own ego if you
didn't read the comics he catches a
bullet from lori in the actual end of
the comics which is this is a callback
to that so the whole conclusion of this
story
is pretty fantastic and that we see as
hubris the way that he looks so
victorious here we know that's probably
going to be a setup
can't help but feel terrible for the
crook shanks and the phillips
especially knowing that their god is
going to be destroyed later on
as a complete side track i'd like to
think that dr manhattan took angela
there for their first date the one that
he was asking her for dinner you know
and when they met in saigon so at least
we can keep in the back of our mind that
if she is the new manhattan and she can
teleport all around that she knows about
the wonderful crook shanks's
and phillips's on europa and will go to
visit them but otherwise you know
they're just there
and adrian didn't do anything except for
use them as a way to get off of there
which is pretty sad in the end
although i really enjoyed the crook
shanks putting on
the headband right before he goes into
the craft and by this point we all
figured out that he was probably gonna
be
turned into a statue and that was fun to
see get paid off
the next big moment was looking glass's
return we knew he would show back up and
he did
i liked how they paired him up with lori
and kept those two characters together
this pays off in a big way later when
they're in karnak
because i kept thinking he was going to
shoot adrian white in the face at any
moment
to get revenge for the squid attack and
all the problems that that caused him in
his life we'll come back to that in a
second because
right after looking glass shows up dr
manhattan is teleported in
and that leads us into the next big
moment which is senator keane's big
speech
now the speech is fantastic on so many
levels
we see that his father's been brought in
his father remember is the one that got
masked vigilantes
outlawed back in the 70s we hear that
their
problem is based on the fact that a
liberal president has been in charge and
that's caused so many problems for the
people who
used to be in power and like i said this
really is a fantastic speech
he says first they took our guns and
then they made us say
we were sorry and he could say something
like sorry
for the alleged sins of people that died
generations before we were born
sorry for the color of our skin and not
see the irony in what they're trying to
do here
it's perfect so we find out what their
gripe is which isn't surprising
we find out how they got the plan to get
dr manhattan we found out that he chose
to wear the
government-issued underwear that dr
manhattan wears in the comic for the big
event
and he tells angela when she arrives
that he's going to squeeze her man down
like a grape and drink him up
which is great because when we see him
later he looks like the one who's been
squeezed
as a grape speaking of cyclops the next
big moment
is them getting lasered by lady true
this was completely satisfying to watch
and there's not too much to say about it
except for way to go
lady true at least you did something
good before your story ended
the next moment would be ozzy saving the
world again
dr manhattan is able to use the keen goo
to teleport them back to karnak
ozymandias gets a plan
to freeze the squid and start a squid
fall
over tulsa that will be like a gatlin
gun going off i really enjoyed how he
said it takes one to no one after he
called his own daughter
a narcissist i certainly took note when
he corrected
looking glass saying i saved humanity
you ignorant
hayseed and like i said the whole time
they were there i just kept wondering if
he was gonna do
something that was gonna cause looking
glass to shoot him in the face
everything about his plan and the way
that it was implemented was great
especially lady true looking through the
hole in her hand when the first squid
hits her
and the whole scene at karnak set up the
next moment which
is lori's conclusion and the arrest of
adrian bite i wondered about this in the
questions video i made right before the
finale came out
if what he did will get out there this
doesn't answer that question but we do
know that they took him prisoner
in archie the original al ship which was
awesome that they had that there at
karnak
and they took him into custody this is a
pretty good riff on the comics ending
because
it's similar to rorschach sending his
journal out we don't know what effect
that's going to have to the lasting
piece after things settled down
we know lady true's been defeated we
know that john osterman
dr manhattan as such has been destroyed
but when the dust settles we're really
not sure exactly how things will play
out going forward
and that part of the ending at least
feels like a watchman ending
the next big moment was the conclusion
to will's story
of course like i said we saw cyclops top
brass get
lasered they won't be causing any
problems anytime soon
that was the deal that will made he
would give up dr manhattan
if lady true would take care of cyclops
the whole idea of nothing
ever ends comes to mind here killing the
leaders of cyclops doesn't end
white supremacy it doesn't end racial
injustice
in the same way that dropping a squid on
new york ended nuclear war
at least at that moment it didn't erase
the fact that people have that inside of
them that they wore with each other
and that sooner or later there would be
something to take the nuclear threat's
place
and that's why dr manhattan told adrian
bite nothing ever ends
so killing these guys didn't end racism
but it is nice to see hood of justice
get justice as far as cyclops is
concerned
and this is a little bit more palatable
since 3 million people didn't have to
die just the ones that were in that room
and them dying will be a blow to the
power structure that's set up
inside their organizations and to bring
it all full circle it happened in
greenwood it happened where the tulsa
race massacre happened that well
witnessed as a boy
the conversation between will and angela
was fantastic
filling us in on how he got there him
knowing that she had the pills
and took them so she understands how he
became
hooded justice and what he went through
there's a really nice touch here where
he asked her how she felt when she put
on the hood how it made him feel
and she said angry and he said yeah
that's right except for
that it was really fear and hurt he
showed sympathy for her
in losing dr manhattan and we learned
that it was dr manhattan's plan
all along and i really liked how he said
based on what he could do
he could have done more he said he was a
good man but he could have done more
and that leads into the final big moment
which is john osterman's end and the
conclusion
of the dr manhattan calhatton and
angela's love story
we learned that it was his plan he knew
he was gonna die
in the moments just before he breaks
apart there's a fantastic moment where
angela is trying to get him to fight
trying to get him to stay
she asks him where he's at and he says
i'm in every moment we were together
all at once i love you angela and damn
just damn it was incredible what a way
to go out
and of course we go back to the house
and after talking with will
angela discovers the egg we see her eat
the egg we don't know if she got
all of his powers some of his powers we
don't know what happened
and it's a cliffhanger in a way but it
actually isn't the kind of cliffhanger
that needs to be answered
the big threat has been stopped lady
true wasn't able to turn herself into a
god
ozymandias is in custody and according
to pedipedia
agent dale pedi has been fired from the
fbi he's no longer an agent but he's
staying behind in tulsa
to try to get to the bottom of what
really happened so we don't know what's
going to happen with president redford
he would be complicit in covering up
adrian bytes plan
that could mean that things will
continue the way they're going
adrian will never have to be held
accountable for what he did
but angela may be dr manhattan agent
pedi who is definitely lube man might be
out there in the world
dan dryberg who is night owl too is
still in federal custody
he knows the truth lori blake's still
out there
and perhaps has a great new relationship
with mirror guy
aka looking glass but it has come to an
end the main story in tulsa for right
now
has concluded the story of dr manhattan
being created in gila flats when john
osterman was tore apart at the atomic
level
and then reassembled himself to become a
blue god there's an ending to that
and i hope that there's more watchmen to
come but we'll wait and see how that
goes
i'm gonna leave the video there let me
know in the comments what your favorite
moments were
i'm gonna go listen to the official
podcast and read all the interviews and
then i'll probably come back with a deep
dive
in the next couple of days i enjoyed
this finale it answered most of the
questions i wanted answered
i think that a lot of people probably
liked it but there will be a lot of
people who don't so let me know what you
think
what would you have liked to seem
different how are you feeling about a
season two now
and what do you think happened when
angela put her foot
on top of that water in the pool it was
important for later please like this
video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching guys
thanks for watching
watchmen with me this season i'll talk
to you soon